solarenergie aus dem weltraum und der
bau hat schon begonnen die große vision
sonnenenergie im alleingang diese gründe
zur erde schicken man sieht dort dann in
strom umzuwandeln und ins netz
einzuspeisen das weltall als eine
unerschöpfliche und regenerative
energiequelle nicht nur die europäische
raumfahrtagentur esa und das us-militär
haben große pläne china hat sogar schon
mit den vorarbeiten für ein
solarkraftwerk im all begonnen doch es
gibt noch einige hürden klicks um
science im future gibt es dreimal pro
woche spannende science wie das
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur so verpasst ihr nichts los
geht's
herzlich willkommen
ein solarkraftwerk im weltalls schon vor
80 jahren hatte der
science-fiction-autor isaac asimov solch
eine idee beschrieben ein solarkraftwerk
im weltraum dass die gesammelte energie
auf die erde schickt und zwar mit der
hilfe von mikrowellen strahlen nur kurze
zeit später wurde aus dieser science
fiction idee das forschungsgebiet
verschiedener forschen der weltweit denn
die vorteile einer solchen idee liegen
auf der hand dort oben den weltall
scheint die sonne fast ununterbrochen
und das zuverlässiger und stärker als an
jedem ort der erde und an möglichen
ideen und konzepten mangelt es nicht es
gebe viele möglichkeiten das als
unerschöpfliche und regenerative
energiequelle zu nutzen china geht einen
solchen plan jetzt konkret an das ziel
der bau eines großen solarkraftwerke mal
solch eine technologie könnte dann auch
die stromversorgung der chinesisch
russischen internationalen mond
forschungsstation sicherstellen im
letzten jahr sind erste tests gelaufen
und der bau der basis der aktion auf der
erde ist bereits in vollem gange wow wie
genau soll die technologie funktionieren
und sind die pläne realistisch die
antworten auf all diese spannenden
fragen und noch viel mehr gibt es jetzt
hier bei pixum science im future die
verluste sind riesig dass es klar denn
solaranlagen auf der erde sind nicht nur
vom wetter abhängig und trotz immer
besserer technik bleibt es dabei dass an
bedeckten tagen deutlich weniger strom
produziert werden kann als an
sommertagen ohne wolken am himmel und es
gibt einen weiteren nachteil denn der
anteil des kurzweiligen blauen lichts
wird durch die atmosphäre gestreut und
kann so bei weitem nicht mehr so gut
genutzt werden insgesamt sind es bis zu
60 prozent der sonnenenergie die durch
diese limitierenden faktoren verloren
gehen die lösung um diese beiden
limitierenden faktoren zu eliminieren
wäre es die sonnenenergie direkt aus dem
weltall zu ernten im orbit scheint die
sonne etwa acht mal intensiver als am
erdboden so erzeugt sie pro quadratmeter
knapp 1400 watt und das zu jeder zeit
hier gibt es den wechsel von tag und
nacht nicht selbst wenn die station
geostationäre um die erde kreist ist der
erdschatten nur minimal und zudem stören
auch keine wolken keine frage solche
weltraum bestückten solartechnologien
könnten europa enorm dabei helfen bis
zum jahr 2050 kohlenstoff neutral zu
werden an vorschlägen zur
energiegewinnung im all mangelt es
jedenfalls nicht ganz im gegenteil dazu
sagt der us ingenieur jan menkens im
forbes magazin die idee der
sonnenenergie aus dem ball scheint eine
wiedergeburt zu erleben und das liegt
wohl daran dass nun endlich die
technologie zu ihrer umsetzung existiert
auch europa ist mit am start die
europäische weltraumagentur esa hat
einen ideenwettbewerb zum thema energie
aus dem all ins leben gerufen von 85
eingereichten konzepten wurden 16
ausgewählt die noch einmal detaillierter
ausgearbeitet werden soll von der esa
heißt es dass es höchste zeit sei den
einfallsreichtum der ingenieure
anzuzapfen und schlüssel technologien
voranzutreiben das motto mit jeder
innovation kommen wir dem ziel ein stück
näher
auch japan ist mit am start bis zum jahr
2030 möchte der inselstaat ein
photovoltaik kraftwerk mit einer
leistung im gigawatt bereich auf einer
geostationären umlaufbahn positionieren
mit der hilfe von energiereichen
mikrowellen oder lasern soll die
sonnenenergie dann zur erde gelangen
zahlreiche
photovoltaik elemente könnten laut plan
in einem ersten schritt ins all
transportiert werden dort werden sie
dann zu risiken solaris in quadrath
kilometer größe zusammengesetzt laser
oder energiereiche mikrowellen sollen
den sonnenstrom dann auf die erde
bringen die empfangsantennen auf der
erde könnten auf schwimm plattformen
platziert werden die im meer oder auf
gewässern im landesinneren schwimmt
beteiligt sind einige bekannte
japanische firmen wie etwa mitsubishi
und fuji zog wie zum beispiel sagt dazu
da die solarenergie sauber und
unerschöpflich ist glauben wir dass wir
mit dem space solar power system einen
beitrag zur überwindung der energie
engpässe auf der ehre und der
klimaerwärmung leisten können erst
anfang 2000 21 hatten wir hier bei
klicks umsatz um features von den us
bemühungen in diesem bereich berichtet
im mai 2020 hatten die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
des us militärs ein programm also ein
photovoltaik radio frequency antenna
module mit hilfe der unbemannten drohne
x-37b in eine niedrige umlaufbahn
geschossen diese drohne mit dem
solarpanel umrundet die erde im 90
minuten takt das ziel die sonnenenergie
über solarpaneele im orbit auffangen und
diese energie dann über einen
mikrowellen laser zur erde schießen
dieser kann besser als die
sonnenstrahlen die wolkendecke durch
trinken der beteiligte us elektro
ingenieur paul scheffer geht davon aus
dass diese idee die energieversorgung
revolutionieren könnte doch noch geht es
lediglich darum zu schauen was geht die
tests sollen klären wie effizient und
praktisch umsetzbar diese pläne sind
doch paul schäfer ist überzeugt er sagt
in einem interview im weltall ist sorgen
licht heller als irgendwo auf der erde
dort ist es nie bewölkt es regnet nicht
und in der passenden umlaufbahn wird es
auch niemals wirklich nacht ist es auf
der erde hingegen eine woche oder einen
monat lang wirklich kommt nicht viel
sonnenlicht an das muss man sich mal
vorstellen ein satellit selbst im
sogenannten geostationären orbit könnte
bei optimal gewählten bahndaten zu 99,8
derzeit
sonnenstrahlung einfangen ein
mikrowellen strahlt der die
sonnenenergie durch die wolken zu erde
beben soll könnte dann sogar beliebig
ausgerichtet werden so zumindest die
theorie dazu der us-forscher port
scheffel wir können die energie nach
chicago schicken und einen
sekundenbruchteil später falls nötig
nach london oder brasilien in der praxis
funktioniert das so allerdings noch
nicht dass das militär soll hinterher
ist diese technologie nach vorne zu
bringen hat vor allem einen grund nicht
der klimaschutz steht hier im
vordergrund sondern militärische
operationen die damit optimiert werden
könnten denn bislang benötigen
militärbasen auf feindlichem gebiet
diese generatoren wo man strom zu kommen
der brennstoff dafür muss mit tankwagen
angeliefert werden ein schwachpunkt und
leichtes angriffsziel das durch energie
aus dem all mit einem mal eliminiert der
konkrete pläne zum thema solarenergie
aus dem all kommen jetzt aus china
realisiert werden soll ein originales
riesiges solarkraftwerk das konzept
stammt aus dem jahr 2010 doch bereits
mehrmals wurden die vorbereitungen aus
finanziellen oder politischen gründen
gestoppt laut medienberichten gibt es
aber jetzt endlich grünes licht der
vizepräsident der chinesischen akademie
für weltraumtechnik die hatte vor drei
jahren im staatsbad science and
technology daily verkündet dass china
als erstes land ein solarkraftwerk im
weltall mit praktischer bedeutung
errichten werde derzeit baut die
volksrepublik wird bereits an der
basisstation auf der erde und zwar in
der nähe der metropole chongqing
hier sollen dann die mikrowellen die aus
dem all gesendet werden in strom
umgewandelt werden noch 2021 sollen
erste übertragungs tests stattgefunden
haben das könnte mit der hilfe von
helium fesselballons passieren die man
zunächst in einer höhe von 300 metern
später dann in einer höhe von 2
kilometern schicken will in acht jahren
also im jahr 2030 könnte dann eine
kleine teststation im all installiert
werden so könnte ganz schritt für
schritt getestet werden wie die
umwandlung von solarenergie in
mikrowellen funktioniert auch der
empfang der strahlen auf der erde sowie
die rückumwandlung soll in tests geprüft
werden im jahr 2050 könnte dann eine
riesiges solarkraftwerk im ort gebaut
werden was dann den chinesischen plänen
zufolge solarstrom im megawattbereich
produzieren könnte dazu werde gerade
eine neue schwerlast rakete entwickelt
heißt es aus china hunderte von starts
wären notwendig um solch ein projekt zu
realisieren doch nicht nur auf der erde
könnte man von dieser technologie
profitieren auch die stromversorgung der
geplanten chinesisch russischen
internationalen mond forschungsstation
könnte so eines tages sicher gestellt
werden doch bis es soweit ist muss noch
einiges an geld in forschung investiert
werden die zwei größten
herausforderungen die noch angegangen
werden müssen jetzt kurz im überblick
der prozess die im all gewonnene energie
mikrowellen umzuwandeln zu senden und in
strom umzuwandeln läuft noch nicht
wirklich effizient ein neuseeländisches
unternehmen aber hat jetzt hilfe von
metamaterialien an den start gebracht
die es ermöglichen sollen mehrere
kilowatt elektrischer leistung über
einige zehn kilometer effizient zu
übertragen doch auch die transportkosten
für solche projekte sind nicht zu
vernachlässigen um kraftwerke bauen zu
können müssten tonnenweise material ins
all transportiert werden wirtschaftlich
gesehen macht das beim jetzigen stand
noch keinen sinn genau daran arbeitet
die forschungsgruppe vom california
institute of technology die idee der
fachleute ist ein modulares system das
sich im all zusammen setzt und zudem
werden raumflüge mit dem starship von
einem mast spacex immer preiswerter
jungfernflug soll ja dieses jahr noch
seien alle energieprobleme auf einen
schlag gelöst großer durchbruch bei der
kernfusion in den usa anklicken
anschauen und abonnieren bis dann bleibt
dran